we're told that jared is twice the age
of his brother peter
so jared is twice the age of his brother
peter peter is four years old
peter is four years old and jared is
twice the age of his brother peter so
jared is twice peter's age of four and
then they tell us
talia's age is three times jared's age
how old are talia and jared so tally is
age
is three times jared's age so let's
write this down we have peter is four
years old so peter
peter's age
peter's age he's four years old jared is
twice the age of his brother peter so
jared
let me do that in yellow
so jared that's not yellow
jared jared is twice the age of his
brother so twice
twice is the same thing as two times
two times the age of his brother we
could though you could say jared is
twice the age of his brother or jared is
two times the age of his brother well
his brother is four they told us that
right over there so jared is going to be
two times four years old two times four
years old and if you know your
multiplication tables you know that's
the same thing as eight two times four
is eight four times two is eight or you
know this is the same thing as peter's
age twice which is the same thing as
four plus four that would also get you
eight
so this would give you so jared's age is
equal to eight
and then finally they say talia's age so
let me write talia's talia
right over here
talia's age and they say it they tell it
to us right over here it's three times
jared's age so talia's age is three
times jared's age well we were able to
figure out jayara's age it is eight
it is three times jared's age if you
know your multiplication tables this
should maybe jump out at you and your
multiplication tables really are one of
those things in mathematics that you
should just just really just know back
and forth just because it'll make the
rest of your life very very very simple
but or you could view three times eight
as literally eight three times so it's
eight plus eight plus eight eight plus
eight is sixteen sixteen plus eight is
twenty four
so three times eight is twenty four so
peter is four jared is eight and talia
is 24.